[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a great series i'm in
uh season two it's called city on a hill
it airs sundays on showtime at 9 eastern
9 pacific
kevin bacon the great actor he plays uh
a detective
jackie raw jackie f and raw
and kevin bacon joins us on the program
how would you describe your character is
jackie a good guy or a bad guy
uh well jackie is a complicated guy
um you know
i tend to not really put my characters
into bad or
good because i've done so many horrible
things as as an
actor i mean in the parts that i've
played you know inexcusable kinds of
things
but while i'm playing these people i
have to sort of stay
in their shoes so i really feel like
it's up to the audience to make their
um their decisions about um
whether or not they like him or i mean
let's put it this way if somebody finds
him to be a good guy then that's on you
i i don't think
i think it's pretty tough to to explain
but he's also
you know complicated i mean one of the
interesting things about jackie is that
he has a very very difficult uh
upbringing which is going to become
clearer and clearer this season uh and
but he you know gets himself into school
he comes from the streets comes from
nothing you know
and and uh gets incredibly well educated
so there's this kind of juxtaposition
between
being very very streetwise but also very
very well read
and able to just kind of pull up
things out of his hard drive
historically whether they're true or not
you know
it's it's it's a fascinating side to him
i think yeah a lot of quotes
from him uh but do you does your wife
ever look at you and say
like i didn't know that was inside you
wow that's a really good
question uh i i think that
after 32 years um
i don't think i've ever done anything
that's sort of like she's seen me do it
in a film and it kind of scares her or
kind of puts her off from me
because she's an actor too so she knows
that these are
this is our job to make it look like
it's believable
um but the most exciting thing for me
and the greatest joy that i would have
is to show her
a scene and have her say
okay that surprised me in terms of that
choice that you made
there because she knows all my tricks
she's seen everything i've done
she knows all my you know so if i can if
i can kind of
like show a new quality to her
and she sees it that's a thrill for me
yeah but sleepers is pretty dark stuff
oh yeah no it's horrible
i've done like i said i mean i've just
done just the worst things
you know when i became an actor
i didn't want to be just the boy next
door
and you know physically i think when i
was just starting out
that was the way people would sort of
put me in that
category right i mean um and
and uh so i had to fight against that
and i think part of that fight for me
was being able to um go down some dark
roads in terms of the characters that i
played but then
you have a movie like footloose so you
have footloose early so
we see you as boy that guy he's the
energetic guy that
he's doing the do-gooder and i think
because of that when you start to do the
dark stuff it's like whoa wait a minute
here
yeah i mean after footloose people
really wanted me
look hollywood has very little
imagination when it comes to casting
um you know most people
end up doing kind of the same thing
right
i mean you even our even some of our
great actors you know they
they they they are the funny guy
or the nerdy one or the romantic dude or
the gangster or you know whatever it is
you can try to kind of
veer off to the side every once in a
while but hollywood really wants you to
kind of stay in that and so does the
audience
frankly in a way so after footloose you
know what people wanted me to do was
that again or some sort of version of
that and i tried you know
a couple of times but it didn't really
feel
it didn't feel right to me not to who i
am
or what i wanted to be as an actor were
you offered dirty dancing
uh no i don't think i was no was that
after footloose i guess it was
i'm just thinking of all that you know
you didn't get saturday night fever
no i didn't no that's true that's true
but if you look the next
here's a here's a little uh tidbit the
next
movie that i did after footloose was
called quicksilver and i played a bike
messenger yeah and
i wanted to do the movie because it was
pitched to me at this as this sort of
like
you know kind of gritty new york
supposed to take place in new york
new york thing about a guy loses money
on wall street he becomes you know was
like a street wise
it was the director kept saying to me i
just love martin scorsese i just love
martin scorsese i want to make mean
streets right
it's not what they had in mind at all
and when you end up
seeing the movie i actually have a uh
a a a dancing what do you call it a
padded um
with a a ballerina where i'm i'm dancing
on a bike i'm doing like tricks i had to
learn to do
stunts on a stunt cycle and she's
dancing around me so basically they were
like
we're taking the footloose kid and we're
putting them in this bike move but it
has to be a bike dancing number and
you should check it out it's hilarious
actually if you haven't seen it
you're from philly but you have to have
a boston accent
um the difference between those two
oh huge huge i mean you know accents
um if you look at accents on the on the
east coast you know they kind of slide
in a way and and boston is is in this
weird way i mean for one thing the
the um the osap the o sound in philly is
a really specific
sound you know you go you you flatten
your a's and you say i'm going to get a
coke
you know and that's the most specific
sound
um in in boston
totally different i can't think of what
it is now totally different
sound and then it kind of slides down
through new york and you hear it change
and after it moves out of philadelphia
it becomes more extreme to get to
baltimore
you know like everyone's talking like
this in baltimore
even more extreme and then it sort of
slides into a virginia axe and then sort
of morphs into a southern accent
it's a really fascinating thing to me i
i hope that
we never i find accidents to be like
national treasures
and i hope that we never lose it um
i've ended up in boston so many times
uh between black mass and patriot stay
in ripd and mystic river and so i've
i've been asked to be a
bostonian i've only been asked to be a
philadelphian once
which was a film called the woodsman and
i would love to be able to
you know use my own accent in a film my
daughter is actually doing a
uh thing called mayor of easton now
uh which is on hbo max and she
like came to me asking me about he kept
calling me saying
dad how would i say this
[Laughter]
wasn't your character's name jimmy dolan
jimmy dolan yeah and you're and you're a
knicks fan
yeah yeah yeah you know what i got to
tell you i don't think i've ever really
even made that connection
what i don't even know if i've ever made
that connect i mean somebody must have
mentioned that to me before but
but yeah that is that is kind of where
nick's about
uh six in a row right yeah they're
playing well yeah
yeah yeah but that's cool it's super
cool
uh by the way we're talking to kevin
bacon uh city on a hill airs sundays on
showtime at nine eastern
and pacific how would you rate your
basketball game by the way terrible
absolutely terrible i mean i
we we played a little bit of basketball
there was one
house in my neighborhood that had a had
a uh rim on
this little street but i really and
one of the things about it though is
like you know philadelphia has tiny tiny
little streets
and and and they have these um
uh these posts these metal posts that
have been there for years i think to
keep people from parking on the on the
thing so
so you'd come up and you'd you know go
for a layup and hit the post with you
i mean it was it was just absolutely
terrible so we were playing more sort of
like
football or half ball or or you know
something like that and first off i also
want to say that i'm really not
a natural athlete um i
i just am not a good ball player
um but who trains you so i was trained
for for the air up there um well the
first thing that i did was
uh uh went and visited steve lavin
because i was playing a coach and um
steve was
you know kind of helpful i guess he was
an assistant coach
at ucla i think at that time maybe
i think um and you know so i got a
chance to kind of see what that side of
it was
and then i went and started um you know
using a gym
um and then eventually bob mcadoo
became my my coach and bob came to
africa with us
and mcadoo once said that the hardest
thing he ever had to do in his career
was making me look like a basketball
player
which is one of my favorite quotes um
but he was a great guy and uh one of my
favorite
moments was they had to get some shots
of you know just cutaways of a basket of
a ball going through a basket
and he just stands like at the top of
the key and just
starts throwing them in one after
another his feet
never leaving the ground um i guess it
was a jump shot
and uh and they're just going i mean i
watched ice
i i must have been 60 balls go in or
something like that it was just crazy
and
the camera just kept rolling and i don't
know why they needed so many of them but
it was a great moment
well he was such a great outside shooter
he had a unique
shot unique release to it but did he
think that you were going to somehow
pick up on
how he was shooting that would help your
game uh
he could have dreamt
but uh it wasn't going to happen uh it's
great to hear from you i love this
series
um did you know that uh aldis was in
friday night lights
first yeah i did know that so he was the
quarterback
in new orleans who was transferring in
and uh you guys you guys got
something going on there it's a great
rivalry between you two
i love working with elvis he's such a
he's such a
great great man and and such a great
actor and when i get
when i get a scene he was he was
actually cast before i was in city on a
hill
and um so when i we when we walked on
the set
i think our first scene if i remember
correctly was the scene where we meet
for the first time
i didn't know i had i didn't watch uh
friday night lights i have to go back
someday
because everyone loves it but i just
never it just wasn't a show that was on
my radar
um and you know we
we did one take and i was like oh this
is going to be great
i'm going to love i'm going to love
getting in the ring with this guy
because he's so
present and he's so um
you know you throw something at him and
he throws it back and
and and it's when i get us when i get a
script if there's a scene between the
two of us
um it's i know it's golden how many
cigarettes do you smoke an episode
yeah a lot although i can tell you that
sin once we and i don't think i will
ever anymore i'll tell you why because
uh when they're herbal cigarettes by the
way um
when we shut down um after
we shut down after the first two
episodes and when we started back up
the protocols were no smoke on the set
at all it was something having to do
with
um uh the the the coveted particles
being able to hang on to smoke
earlier like you know a lot of times on
films you use what we call atmosphere
which is you know kind of a smoky kind
of look to get the light
shining through and stuff like that or
if you're in a bar and it's supposed to
be cigarettes
but we weren't allowed to smoke and i
wasn't allowed to smoke so um
it was all a digital effect from this
second episode on so i don't think i'll
ever have to smoke again oh now you
ruined it for me see i thought you were
smoking these heaters and i was going
god your wife has to be yelling at you
no
no it's not good it's not good i mean
they are herbal but i don't
think they're you know who knows yeah uh
well congrats on the series and uh great
to talk to you again kevin thank you for
joining us
i'm so happy always to talk to you man
it's it's it's
it's great even uh even in this
situation
thank you bud all right take care that's
kevin bacon